thank you james very much uh good
afternoon members
or good evening as we should say now and
officers and welcome to this planning
committee meeting of the
2nd of december um as usual
i will call out your names those who are
on committee
uh and if you obviously are here and you
could just acknowledge that for me
please
uh so always start it
there in any order no i believe they're
in enough vessel order now which is nice
uh
uh councilman coleman cook yeah chair
councillor alban i think i'm here chair
yeah
i disagree with that um count
councillor bayford here and
curry here chair councilman dennis
now councillor duckworth
councillor ghana i'm here chair
councillor heart here jet
council akeem here chair council ratigan
councillor scott councillor taylor
has somebody just um arrived
did you get did you get me me and mick
did you did you hear me say
don't know oh sorry
sorry uh move on um by the way
thank you councillor and thank you uh
councillor rights
councillor right thank you and obviously
i'm here as well as usual members
it's council paul moore substituting
scott
well i will come to you in a moment okay
thank you i go through the main
planning committee to start with and i
will come back to apologies on the
agenda item
uh right view housekeeping
um and advice to yourselves um if you
have technical difficulties during the
meeting
then please contact the democratic
service officer
who is on call who will want to assist
you today it is
katie and her number is 577046
and her number has appeared in the chat
box
i will ask participants to mute their
microphone when you are not speaking
so this minimizes background noise and
will help everyone
who is listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be used when the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
put your name in the chat box on the
right hand side
and i always say this members i think
you know by now
i do see who puts their name on and
make a note so if i don't acknowledge
you that doesn't mean to say i haven't
seen it but if i do miss you out at the
end of debate
please shout at me um
the environment side of things would
everybody present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned too silent and they are not to be
used to make or receive calls while this
meeting is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of
this meeting
uh you also are aware uh that this note
this meeting is being live streamed to
members of the public
and the recording will be available on
the council was
a youtube channel after the meeting
uh the order of business uh this
afternoon uh would members please note
that a gender item 4a
that is flats 2 and 4 cyan
court 3 to 4 zion hill
ramsgate has been withdrawn from the
agenda due to an issue that has come to
light
with the application
there are no counsellors unless i hear
different now
who wish to speak uh who are online
under procedure 20.1
if there is anybody online could they
please
let me know now
okay thank you very much uh
item agenda item one apologies for
absence
i i have received apologies from
matthew scott who has had to continue
working this afternoon
and he is substituted by councillor paul
moore
so welcome councillor more to planning
agenda item two are there any
declarations of interest please
uh excuse me uh chair i'd just like to
say um
councillor duckworth uh gave her
apologies
okay thank you thank you councillor
curry
agenda item three approving minutes uh
the last meeting which was held on the
11th of well it was
the meeting before the 11th november
2020
to be approved by myself
i hope everybody's read the minutes who
were on committee then
if i could have a proposal please i'll
propose that
sure thank you council coleman cook a
second to please
i was going to connect here councillor
thank you
do members agree agreed
yeah great thank you thank you
uh agenda item for uh scheduled planning
applications and public speaking where
there is no public speaking
again site visit members you're aware
that
these cannot be held under the present
circumstances
of the kobe regulations
agenda item 4a which i've just mentioned
to you the flats two and four
zion court this item has been
withdrawn agenda item
4b which is the planning application of
one seven score farm cottages
a street
as this is the remaining item on the
agenda and has not been reserved for
public speaking
does any member of this committee wish
to reserve the application
for debate
uh chairman uh council elder chairman i
i think that we should debate this as
this
is uh as this is against
policy so i think members should
look at the application chair and then
make its decision
thank you thank you very much councillor
alban a fair comment
um so what i would do i'll go straight
in
to um the officer which i believe
is in presenting on this one
yes chair uh i will just present my
screen
so the application site is outlined in
red
so that includes number one a seven
score
farm uh cottage um
the application is for the erection of a
detached uh
two-story property with accommodation
within the roof slope
um the
the site is located to the
west of cliffwind so if you're looking
at the
aerial image here you have the a256
running running in the middle of the
screen on the left hand side here you
have cottington road and ebs fleet lane
north and then the site is where
the uh where the dot on google is here
so you can see the relationship with
uh the cliffs and settlement
so going in into a bit more detail um so
this is
absolutely north you have a collection
of properties
and also the the farm uh the site
is uh in this area here
so this is a turned around image but you
can see the
more detail in terms of the row of
residential properties
that's present on the road so the site
is the garden area
the side garden of uh number one here
uh and this is a view again a 3d image
from google just to show again the
relationship between the farm buildings
and the rest of the properties along
this road
this is just another image just showing
the other angle so showing the
properties of further
to the north and then the rear of the
site as well
so this is uh the actual site itself so
this is from the the front of the site
and this is looking again a view
slightly elevated
from google just to show the
relationship between
property number one uh seven score farm
cottages
and uh to the orchards which is the
dwelling on the left hand side here with
the site
uh in the middle this is a further back
view so you can see there's quite a
transition
quite change between the the building
line of those two properties at the
moment
and then the view from the other side of
the site so you can see the the
properties that are directly fronting
the street
uh the pair there and the site will
drift here where you can see the sort of
single story
shed that's in the center of the image
this is a view from cottington road of
the site so you can see
here that you have the farm buildings in
the center
so the site is approximately in this
area
here so you can see that the the two
semi-detached properties uh
number one and two seven score farm
cottages uh
is this this structure here so we are
sort of in
in that that area for the dwelling
so this is the existing site plan uh
showing
uh the the application site so you have
the shed
that i was talking about earlier in this
area here
so what's proposed is to cite a dwelling
set back from
uh the front building line of number one
uh but
in front of uh the existing dwelling
number two and the neighboring property
with a new crossover put in with access
for parking
this is the design of the property
itself
so it has composite windows
predominantly
aluminium with uh then cladding at first
floor level
and uh render at ground floor
these are v-locks windows in the roof
slope and at the rear
you have uh the dormer windows within
the roof slope to serve the roof
accommodation
and then the just the rear windows and
the design of those
the side elevation so this is the south
elevation
um so these two windows are proposed to
be obscure glazed and fitted with
uh restrictors to restrict the ability
of them to open because
uh they are casement windows so they
open from the side
and then the north elevation um
which obviously shows a window which is
also to be obscure glazed
and fitted with restrictors
so the dwelling as proposed is a four
bedroom
dwelling so you can see ground floor
here on the left hand side
the first floor here and then
the roof accommodation on the right hand
side
so this is a flat view of the street
scene so
two orchard view is on the left-hand
side so this is the dwelling that's set
back from the road uh seven school farm
cottages which is right on the road
so the proposal will
situate the dwelling between the two
properties
so you can see it's set off away from
the neighbor on the the left hand side
so there's a there is a distance there
obviously
there's a distance and it's set further
forward as well as the distance to
ensure
to ensure that the parking area is
retained for for number one
uh seven school farm cottages
and then this is a sectional view
from the south looking north so you can
see number one seven score farm cottages
here and number two orchard view at the
rear
with then the proposal uh going in
between the two and you can see those
windows that we mentioned in terms of
obscure glazing those windows
there if i just go back
to the site plan
um so the application is being reported
to members as
it is a departure from that local plan
because the site sits outside
the urban confines uh however officers
have considered looked at the design of
the
dwelling itself and considered it fits
within the character of the area
the mitigation that's been put in place
to ensure there isn't any impact on the
neighboring properties
is being secured by condition um
but as it's outside the open confines it
it falls as a departure to the plan
and this is because obviously there is
um
with the allocated housing sites and the
urban confines as defined as they are in
the new
adopted local plan um there is whilst
there is a general need for housing
housing outside the urban confines or
the allocated sites is not
is not needed therefore the presumption
needs to be looked as to whether or not
we put
more dwellings in certain locations in
the countryside however in this
particular context
it's not considered by officers that
there is harm to either the intrinsic
uh character of the co of the of the
countryside
uh sorry um or the landscape character
area
as well so in terms of longer views that
where we were looking at the longer
views of the site
it's obviously set in the context of a
row of dwellings
um it doesn't it fills in whilst it
fills in a gap within that street scene
it doesn't fill
an important gap within the countryside
however it is noted and it's this is
commented on in the report
the fact that the site is remote in the
sense
of when we were looking at the original
the first image
uh the fact that is obviously located
within a collection of of
dwellings and business but it is away
from the settlement of cliff's end
and so in terms of weighing up the
environmental dimension of sustainable
development
um you know it doesn't it is in a remote
location therefore there will be a
reliance on
private transportation and so that is
weighed
um against the proposal however
as mentioned there is no actual
intrinsic harm to the countryside nor
the character of the area
nor the landscape character area and
whilst very very modest
there are benefits from providing an
additional dwelling
um very modest benefits but they are
benefits in terms of
the economic development economic
dimension of sustainable development
as well as the social side of uh of the
the test
of sustainable development so therefore
um it is considered that the departure
can be supported
by members and therefore the application
is recommended for approval
we have received the unilateral
undertaking
to secure the mitigation towards the
special protection area
with an appropriate assessment being
carried out by the local authority so
it is a recommendation not to defer and
delegate but to approve
on the base of the safeguarding
conditions and also the unilateral
undertaking that we've received and
checked thank you chairman
uh thank you ian um as you gathered
is he's recommended for approval so i
move the officers recommendation is
adopted
could the vice chair please second oh
second nurture
thank you council coleman cook i have
two speakers at the moment
councillor alban
thank you chair um
i agree with uh mr mr livingston
i think the uh site is sustainable
i think the development is sustainable
i don't think it has an impact it fits
in nicely with
what is surrounding it there's plenty of
space plenty of off-street parking
design is adequate and
therefore i i will be supporting this
application chair thank you uh thank you
councillor auburn
uh councillor bayford thank you chair
yeah i totally agree
i think this is unlike um other
applications we've seen
which are outside the urban confines um
i think it is in a line of houses it's a
quite an attractive
building amongst um a range range of
others
care has been taken to ensure it doesn't
impinge on
on the other dwellings so i i will also
like to
support this application thank you sir
thank you councillor bayford um i can't
see
any other speakers uh so i'm going to
put this to you members
to vote um for approval
if you are for it please say more if
you're against against and if you're
abstaining
um just abstain so i'll go through
uh your names once again uh councillor
coleman cook
for council organ for
councillor bayford or council curry
four councillor ghana
four councillor heart four
councillor keane four chancellor raskin
councillor paul moore four
and myself i'm for it as well um i know
i
get confirmation on the chat line but um
that obviously has been carried
uh thank you james uh members
um that concludes the planning meeting
for this afternoon um i think
uh i've lost a bit um so i thank you all
um very much i know it's been very short
this afternoon
but to say um if you can stay online
for mr livingston to have a few words so
thank you all very much and thank you
council
more for stepping in good
thank you good afternoon thank you